hi I'm Ryan I'm going to be watching the  trailer for Godzilla hopefully it's good  legend any when you are being sent in by  a halo jump I realize not all of you  have had hands-on experience I love that  actor frankly none of us have ever faced  a situation quite like this one before  look at his eyes now I would not be  asking anyone of you to take this leap  I've totally faith in your ability to  succeed is so [ __ ] cool your courage  will never be more needed than it is  today  looks like a badass  you see  you can almost see him  my nipples are rising from my chills  right kids  O'Brien crescens in this  want to see him that's [ __ ] scary  oh yeah Matt looks pretty dope oh [ __ ]  I'm gonna check that [ __ ] out man I  wonder how big his shits are